we have now learned that indeed failed
former president Donald Trump had
documents with nuclear secrets on them
at his house at Mar-A-Lago and the
immediate question becomes what the hell
was he planning to do with those was he
planning to sell them did he sell them
and of course all sorts of speculation
running rampant so let's go back and
start at the top it was speculated that
there might have been uh documents
relating to nuclear capabilities at
Donald Trump's Mar-A-Lago part of the
search warrant served by the FBI at his
home we now have gotten confirmation of
that from the Washington post's Devlin
Barrett and Carol lenig a document
describing a foreign government's
military defenses including nuclear
capabilities was found by FBI agents who
searched former president Donald Trump's
Mar-A-Lago residence and private club
last month according to people people
familiar with the matter
underscoring concerns among U.S
intelligence officials about classified
materials stashed in the Florida
property
some of the seized documents detail top
secret U.S operations so closely guarded
that many senior National Security
officials are kept in the dark about
them only the president some members of
his cabinet or a near-cabinet level
official could authorize other
government officials to know details of
the special access programs
documents about such highly classified
operations require special clearances on
a need to know basis not just a top
secret top secret clearance some special
access programs can have as few as a
couple dozen government Personnel
authorized to know about the operation's
existence records that deal with such
programs are kept under lock and key
almost always in a secure compartmented
information facility with a designated
control officer to keep careful tabs on
their location these documents sometimes
require
the constant surveillance of the
documents to know exactly where they are
at all times
and Trump had him at his house
Trump had him at his house this is
getting worse every single day now the
timing of this release I believe and
many do as well I'm not unique in this
belief I didn't come up with this that
the timing is related to the appointment
of a special Master to oversee the
documents that even Trump's own former
Attorney General William Barr thinks
it's inappropriate and is a decision
that will ultimately be reversed
and I do believe the timing is in order
to counteract that and to sort of say
all right well you figure out a way to
delay things but more and more
information is going to come out now why
would Trump who has a lot of debt
relied on a lot of foreign money to
become president why would Trump keep
documents about the nuclear capabilities
of other countries at his house do you
think Trump is aware that many
adversaries of the United States would
be willing to pay for those documents is
Trump aware that many adversaries of the
United States would love to try to steal
certain documents do we still believe
that there is a perfectly innocent
explanation for this
I don't
I don't and I'm starting to think maybe
it's not true that Trump wanted these
documents so that he could write his
Memoirs or said that they could be in
his Presidential Library which by all
accounts he doesn't even care about now
here is Trump's lawyer one of Trump's
lawyers Alina Haba just yesterday
mocking the idea that the stolen
documents included nuclear secrets this
was yesterday I saw this meme that was
very funny
um on Instagram I believe it was and it
said it's amazing at first it was the
codes to the nuclear weapons now it's
invisible classified documents so she's
mocking the idea
that there were nuclear-related
documents there and yet there are and
yet there are uh you really have to
wonder
what else has Trump done
over the last four five six years
that we haven't even learned about yet
and as I've said before I believed it
would take years to learn the full scope
of what he did and it's taking years
it's taking years and
um this is all you know there's a couple
different possibilities here as I said
about the timing one possibility is this
is the Intel community
fighting back or signaling back about
the special Master decision saying you
know you can put in place a special
master
but we can keep releasing more and more
every day about the damaging reality of
what Donald Trump did the other
possibility here is that the special
Master obviously the intent of that by
Trump is to just slow down what's going
on maybe particularly in the context of
the midterms and the Intel Community
here is saying we can accelerate the
release of this information now I can't
believe I'm actually saying this but
this is potentially treasonous what
Donald Trump has done if you look at a
couple of different statutes 18 U.S code
subsection 794 is called Gathering or
delivering defense information to Aid
Foreign government okay we're talking
about crimes there and uh check Google
the statute and read it for yourself
it's quite lengthy another possibility
18 U.S code 793 Gathering transmitting
or losing defense information
also a crime this is extraordinarily
serious and of course listen at every
step we knew it was serious when we
learned about the investigations we knew
it was serious
when the FBI decided to do the raid we
knew it was serious
when Trump and his cronies started
throwing absurd conflicting explanations
at the wall to see what sticks we knew
it was very serious and now that this
has been found we know it is even more
serious and unfortunately for Trump his
lawyers are rapidly deteriorating when
confronted about these issues
one of our sponsors is betterhelp the
customized online therapy service that
offers video phone and live chat with
your therapist you don't even have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to you fill out a questionnaire to help
assess your specific needs and then
you're matched with a licensed therapist
in under 48 hours you can schedule
secure video and phone sessions you can
exchange unlimited messages with your
therapist and you can request a new
therapist at any time for any reason at
no charge talking to a therapist doesn't
mean there's something wrong with you it
means you're doing something for
yourself and for your Wellness you get
your car serviced you work out you see
the doctor to prevent physical illness
and disease therapy is the same thing
anyone can benefit from it I think it's
very important join the 2 million plus
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with better help get 10
off your first month at Better Health
help.com Pacman the link is down below